[Music]
kent is in tampa hi kent welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave and george thank you so much for
having me sure what's up
um basically i'm looking for permission
to pursue my dreams
i'm a stage manager
in live entertainment mostly working in
cruise ships theme parks and regional
theaters but ultimately i want to work
on broadway musicals and national tours
but obviously to do that i have to live
in new york and that would be a
significant increase in living expenses
and i just wanted to see if there was
sort of a benchmark that you would
suggest hitting before
making that jump i'm 25 years old i have
no debt i have a fully funded actually
an overfunded emergency fund
but moving to new york would basically
take out all of the margin i could make
it work but it would take out all of the
margin but it would also open up uh a
lot more earning potential so i just
wanted to get your thoughts i know it
would be risky but i just want to make
sure it's not stupid and i figured if
anyone is going to be willing to tell me
that it's stupid it would be dave
well ken you've done a great job so far
i don't i this is not the riskiest move
you could make at 25 years old with no
debt in an emergency fund that is over
funded so you're going to be okay this
sounds like this is your dream this is
what you want to do and so i'm making
the move now you want to do it with some
wisdom can you line up a job there or is
this one of those show up do whatever it
takes work at a coffee shop and try to
make this dream happen
uh it's closer to that i have a pretty
good network so i feel like it would
definitely when something becomes
available i would have people that i
could reach out to but it's sort of you
have to you have to be there in order to
get the job kind of thing
can you set your life up to where you'd
be there in 20 minutes
and you can get from tampa to new york
in an hour and a half two hours
tampa to new york city you can jump on
an airplane and get up there in a couple
hours okay
so yeah
it's not like you
um
i mean i think you start working your
network and you get something lined up
and if they want you to come up there
and interview one day fly up there and
interview
and when you land the job then make the
move i i um i might stay in tampa until
i kept and keep my lifestyle costs way
down because your cost of living there
is probably 70 cents on the dollar or
what it is in manhattan
yeah at least
i mean a rent is more than that but the
rest of the cost of living is probably
70 cents on the dollar so um
and you know if you could
and you've got work there that's not a
coffee shop right i don't care i'm with
georgia go do it if you want to go do it
the
lead the way to lower the risk one more
time is to get a whole bunch of stuff
almost dripping out in the pipeline and
then make the move then right now it
sounds like you're just going up there
hoping you can fill the pipeline
yeah i don't know if it would make a
difference in what you would suggest but
a lot of the work that i do um takes me
out of town and they provide housing and
everything so a lot of the work that i
currently am doing i could still
continue to do
in new york it just wouldn't necessarily
be jobs that are in new york if that
makes sense yeah okay all right so you
could keep working while your current a
lot of your current gigs while you look
for the new york break
yes so the only difference here is just
the relocation
precisely definitely doing that head on
baby do it
great well thank you so much i
appreciate it and if you reach the point
that you're going in debt to keep your
dream alive and you're getting ready to
turn your dream into a nightmare move
back
oh for sure
but you know the trip the trick is
you've got the margin here and you've
learned how to look at this with a
critical eye which you already did
before you called us